what is it about me that makes you not
want to sit here honestly yeah like
everything starting with your face first
just like you're smelling something that
doesn't smell good you don't look like
you have bones under your body at all
you're just sort of like an old baby
complete answer when was the last time
you engaged in intercourse do you mean
like a full-on kind of so your apps
there no it's more just like oh gosh
because is it March ready so tired of
being such a dork
yeah good beer want to be a guy that no
matter where they are there's a
possibility he could have sex in a
bathroom I want to be sex in the
bathroom people that's so cool
how do we do this how is this done it
would be nice to meet some girls I'll go
on dates all the time no you don't -
come on Lenny when was the last time you
were out on a date what day is today
Sunday 1986 how you do it you're so put
together are you familiar with giggling
the squeezing it's like a glass of wine
for the primes what are you doing with
your face you're not blinking whatsoever
now girls don't like guys from
upper-middle class Pennsylvania what do
they like they want like bad boys have
been in fight
what's up
I guess I kinda have a [ __ ] side
my people are we're down four years
what's wrong with the glass that's a
nasty Weiser Kovac weirdo you look
really nice
I'm not used to seeing you with this
much makeup is the wine going to
aggravate your IBS I don't smoke
babe come on take a poll okay see what
the future is all about I'm I'm good
thanks
[Music]
your dinner no I just said that Justin
you're poopin
I'm really glad that we're doing this
together you know I'm gonna get up on
the bar I'm putting this on the Internet
oh man that lady took our spot this is
part of our problem we're too passive
hey dumb lower your window so yelling
[Music]
you